bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france d'abord comment
fonctionne cette commission d'enquêté
qui la composent alors c'est une
commission des requêtes qu'on a mis en
place depuis maintenant une dizaine de
jours qui réunit les députés nationaux à
l'assemblée nationale de la france
insoumise et les députés européens les
coordonnées donc par mathilde de
panneaux qui est vice-présidente du
groupe à l'assemblée nationale eric
coquerel et moi même et en fait elle se
traduit par des auditions que nous
organisons alors en visioconférence
version respecter le confinement et des
auditions de personnalités de chercheurs
de syndicalistes de travailleurs de
membres d'associations sur l'ensemble
des sujets qui sont concernés par la
bataille sanitaire avec plusieurs
objectifs un objectif vous l'avez dit de
de contrôle et de vérification des
informations parce que des fois les
gouvernements nous dit quelque chose et
on se rend compte sur le terrain c'est
pas forcément exactement ce qu'on
observe une démarche aussi qui vise à
produire des propositions dans le moment
actuel
et puis aussi qui vise à comprendre et
essayer de tirer des enseignements de ce
que nous observons aujourd'hui qu'est ce
qui ressort des auditions
bon alors j'invite les gens à aller
consulter les auditions sur toutes les
auditions sans son public
on a tiré quelques quelques
enseignements par exemple on a vu
auditionné un syndicaliste des douanes
qui a fait le point et il nous a dit ce
qui nous a beaucoup surpris que entre le
mois de décembre et début du mois de
mars en réalité il y avait eu aucune
commande de masques fait par l'état
français pour pouvoir satisfaire les
objectifs de protection des citoyens
on a pu auditionner l'ancien directeur
de cette usine de fabrication de masques
dans les côtes d'armor qui nous a
expliqué comment comme cette usine a été
fermé il ya deux ans et des alertes qui
avait été lancé au président de la
république au ministère de l'économie
n'ont pas été suivies d'effet
on a pu auditionner des travailleurs par
exemple dans le secteur de
l'aéronautique qui nous disent
qu'aujourd'hui on leur demande de
reprendre l'activité alors que de leur
propre point de vue à eux leur activité
n'est pas une activité essentielle à la
bataille sanitaire voilà pour vous
donner quelques exemples
il ya beaucoup de choses qu'on retire de
ses auditions qui sont à mon avis très
intéressante pour mieux comprendre ce
qui se passe et mieux comprendre aussi
comment on peut améliorer la réponse
politique à la bataille et à la crise
sanitaire que nous connaissons mais
c'est faux
on être aussi qu'on vit une situation
inédite à une crise sanitaire inédite
très peu de pays ils étaient préparés y
compris les plus grandes puissances de
ce monde bien sûr que c'est une
situation particulièrement
exceptionnelle néanmoins je pense que si
nos sociétés sont frappés comme elles le
seront aujourd'hui c'est aussi parce que
les politiques qu a été mis en place ces
dernières années on affaiblit nos
capacités de résistance l'exemple le
plus frappant c'est à quel point on a
accepté pendant des années des
délocalisations d'industrie qui sont
pourtant dans des secteurs qui sont
stratégiques que la production de masse
que les médicaments la production du
matériel médical et c'est ça aussi que
nous payons aujourd'hui de la même
manière les politiques de réduction et
de compression des dépenses publiques
par exemple dans le secteur de la santé
dans on en mesure aujourd'hui les
conséquences alors il s'agit pas de dire
qu' on aurait pu tout imaginer avant il
s'agit de dire d'abord est ce qu'on
appelait des erreurs avant et puis il
s'agit de dire aussi que la
communication et le retard à l'allumage
du gouvernement fait qu'on a le
sentiment de ne pas être dans une
gestion de crise mais dans une gestion
permanente de la pénurie pénurie qu'on
cache ensuite par des que des exercices
de communication ça a été très bien dit
dans vos reportages tout à l'heure sur
le fait que rabat finalement comme on
n'a pas de masque à vous produire on va
dire que ça sert à rien et je pense que
ce défaut de franchise
ce défaut d'anticipation cette
difficulté des fois qu'on a à faire
confiance en la parole politique sur des
choses nous ont répondu et qu'en réalité
ce n'est pas ce qui est observé sur le
terrain et cette difficulté à rompre
avec des dogmes sur le marché
l'intervention de l'état dans l'économie
ça on observe concrètement par exemple
qu'est ce qu'on attend pour nationaliser
lusine luxfer qui est une usine de
production des bouteilles à oxygène dont
on a besoin on a l'impression que sur ça
on se heurte à une forme de dogmes
idéologiques ou quand il faut que l'état
intervienne dans la bataille sanitaires
dont le pilotage la planification de
l'économie pour faire face aux besoins
qu'on observe aujourd'hui est bien là on
se heurte à une difficulté idéologique
voilà ce qu'on essaye de pointe et il
s'agit de le faire de manière
constructive on n'est pas là pour dire
tout ce qui est fait n'est pas bon mais
il s'agit de dire comment on pourrait
améliorer qu'est ce qu'on pourrait faire
mieux et la france est soumise elle se
présente là comme une force qui fait des
propositions
donc dans l'état d'esprit dans lequel on
est est-ce que selon vous on peut parler
d'un masque gates ba avait clairement
sur cette question par exemple d'aider
des masques je pense que tout le monde a
compris désormais que non seulement il
ya eu d'anticipation et on a accepté
année après année de l'idée des stocks
stratégiques que ico prix quant aux
honda ont commencé à comprendre ici au
plus haut niveau de l'état qui allait
avoir un une crise sanitaire d'une
ampleur inégalée
on peut pas dire que les mesures
d'anticipation qui ont été prises à ce
moment-là soit soit soit au point il y
en a eu quasiment aucune jusqu'au début
du mois de mars c'est ce que je vous
disais tout à l'heure et au troisième
mans où vient finalement masquer cette
pénurie par des discours de
communication comme celui du
porte-parole de la gouverne du
gouvernement et qui vous dit ne vous
inquiétez pas les masques de toute façon
vous savez pas vous en servir
donc je pense qu'effectivement sur ce
point là par exemple s'apprend très
concrets sur lesquels on peut dire que
la réponse gouvernementale
honnêtement n'est pas à la hauteur de la
situation et à quoi va servir finalement
cette commission denquête pour la presse
créé sanitaires alors elle sert et elle
vise en tout cas nous comme ça que le
voient à servir déjà tout de suite on
savait que les députés au des
possibilités d'interpellations
d'interpellation des ministres donc des
fois ils utilisent pour leurs
interpellations des éléments qu'on a pu
récupérer dans cette commission denquête
elle vise aussi à en tirer des
enseignements sur des axes ça plutôt
moyen ou long terme
par exemple on a auditionné des
chercheurs qui nous ont pointé le lien
qui peut y avoir entre les politiques de
destruction de l'environnement de la
biodiversité et la multiplication des
épidémies on a pu interroger des
syndicalistes dans le secteur du
médicament qui nous disent attention il
ya urgence à ramener sur tout le
territoire français ou européen des
capacités de production des principes
actifs des médicaments parce que 80% de
ces principes actifs sont aujourd'hui
produits en inde ou en chine
donc on en tire aussi bien sur les
réponses immédiates mais aussi des axes
qui vont prendre un peu plus de temps
mais sur lesquels il faudra pas louper
le coche dans l'après crise parce que
sinon la presse ça sera comme avant et
finalement tout ça n'aura été qu'une
parenthèse et je pense que le pire ce
n'est pas malheureusement la crise mme
si elle est terrible ce serait aussi
qu'on n'arrive pas à en tirer
demain
les ressorts d'un monde nouveau merci
beaucoup manuel bompard d'alain en
direct à nos questions rappelle que vous
êtes eurodéputés de la france info me